foreign
welcome back to the GSB
thank you it's so good to be here Dean
Joss to see you after all these years
and um I have to say Kathleen that I was
looking at the bios of the people with
whom I'm going to have lunch and
was so impressed I almost felt like we
were talking about games and you all are
playing these wildly technical video
games and I'm going to talk to you about
like my games as a kid where we threw
sticks down and then had to pick them up
um truly it's just so exciting to be
here and also to see beloved friends uh
and classmates well we are so excited to
have you here I might be the most
excited though because when I was in
college my professor handed me a copy of
your book the blue sweater and told me
that this is the one book that I have to
read before I start trying to change the
world and I actually brought my coffee
here today
um as you can see it is very well loved
it actually traveled around the world
with me for multiple years and has been
an inspiration for both my career and
for my personal life so thank you thank
you that means a lot
where did you go to school
I went to MIT
yeah that's awesome so we have so much
to talk about you've done some amazing
things both here at Stanford and
afterwards but I want to start with your
family you are the oldest of seven and
your father was in the Army what role
did your upbringing play in both the
work you're doing today I'm the leader
that you've become
um well we were laughing backstage
because I did grow up in a military
immigrant Catholic Family but I don't
I'm not famous for keeping time
um
in a funny way I think because there
were so many of us and not a lot of
income and my dad was in Vietnam three
times we sort of grew up like cowboys
and um and took care of each other as
kids and as the eldest I probably became
very responsible for taking care of all
the other ones too and so I was just
thinking about it recently that all
seven of us are entrepreneurs
um and it may just be that uh
we became unemployable very quickly
because we were such a tribe uh we held
each other but we also had to be
resourceful
we had to make money the the famous
story in our family is that uh
when we were probably I was probably 10
so I don't know what year it was but the
cool kids had Levi's jeans and Converse
sneakers and my mom bought us what we
call dungarees at the Post Exchange and
when we would complain to her that we
were a little humiliated that we had
such bad clothes
um she would say you know you don't need
Brands you know you're novogratsis and
um
my brother would be like what's a
novograts
and so she made a deal with us she would
get us the lousy jeans but we could work
when I was 10. we could work
um to buy the fancy ones and I think
that ethos is probably what made us all
entrepreneurs
well fast forward after college you're
working in a dream job on Wall Street
you're traveling first class around the
world but after three years you decide
to leave and you move to Africa what
prompted such a dramatic shift
um well I think I was actually more an
accidental Banker um it hadn't really
been my dream but
in the interview I learned that I'd be
in 40 countries and again we didn't have
a lot of money so I'd never left the
United States and so I took the job and
in the dream
was this opportunity to see how the
world actually operated and it really
taught me to love the world
um I also gained all these tools that I
used today and saw the power of markets
and then so did I see how especially in
Brazil Latin America at the time how
low-income people were fully kept out of
the banks and it seemed so short-sighted
to me that I wanted to
um
try to use those same tools but to
extend them to people who were
overlooked and underestimated by the
systems
and then after that you went to co-found
rwanda's First microfinance institution
why micro finance and what were some of
the major challenges that you had to
overcome in that endeavor
well so this is 1986 10 years after
Muhammad yunus founded the Grammy bank
and uh I was looking for models and
there were four institutions essentially
that were doing microfinance I tried to
get to Bangladesh but I mean I sent
Professor Nunes a letter but she didn't
write me back and
um it was pretty internet no email and
so um I ended up in Rwanda also sort of
accidentally women had just gotten the
permission to open a bank account
without their husband's signature so
this was really the first step on the
ladder and the idea was
we would extend these loans and they
would build businesses
um what happened was that we extended
these loans and they built their own
business a little bit but they would
only hire their children for the most
part and so that really started making
me think about the power of credit uh
for low-income people to have more
agency more choice in their lives but
also
we had to have something else
so you do some incredible work down
there and then you decide to come here
the GSB why leave that promising work in
Rwanda to come to business school and
what were some of the biggest lessons
you ended up taking away from here
wow it's a great uh question when I was
in Wanda
um
I knew that I wasn't going to spend the
rest of my life there
and
and so it was really important to me to
make it a Rwandan institution not my
institution in fact I had a very
important moment when I got malaria and
the my co-founders came to me and said
well now that you're finally sitting
still
um we want to tell you that you're
moving too fast that
we can't keep up with you we love your
energy we love what you're building but
this is going to be your institution not
ours and
um that was super painful but it gave me
the opportunity to work in Wanda for two
months and I would go to Kenya and I
would come back sometimes we would take
two steps back before we would move
forward and um and meanwhile uh I
started gaining these aspirations to
build bigger companies that most people
aren't entrepreneurs
uh it's a
it's a question that Dr Eunice and I
don't fully agree on I think the gig
economy shows how Innovative what
survivors we are that entrepreneurs are
a little bit crazy I can personally
attest to it
um we build what hasn't been built
before it takes a lot of risk and so
where were those individuals that were
building real companies and then could
we help them find jobs
can we help them employ people and so um
and then the final thing was people were
calling me inogo which means little girl
uh truly realizing who I was as a female
young female in central Africa and so
came to Stanford
um
and it was quite a shock moving from
Kigali to Palo Alto
um
fully dressed in my African Garb
um which was not the uniform of the day
I had uh
um and yet I started to see the the
tools that I wanted that I knew and in
fact many of the studies I did whether
it was regression analysis I would go
back to what I had started in Rwanda and
try to look at the applicability of it I
always knew even while I was here and
then I met this man named John Gardner
who was actually teaching at the Ed
school but taught a class on leadership
in the in the business school and it
turned out that he was the secretary for
health education and Welfare under
President Johnson and it fundamentally
changed my life John really believed in
the power of service like you do and
community and
um and truly became my mentor for the
next 15 years until he died
and uh
my office or the room that I have
meetings in is named for John quotes
with by John and I I think I've really
learned what Legacy is
real Legacy not names on buildings
when I hear John's words in the voices
of young people that I have worked with
in Pakistan and Nigeria and Kenya I
think well there he is
and this is actually what rebirth is and
this is True Legacy comes from investing
in that next Generation me at the time
so that I could go forward and carry his
work forward
even in very different ways that could
only be applicable to my generation I
love that what are some of the the words
that you've heard people around the
world saying that really stand out to
you
um
probably the thing I hear most is um
well you know you have to focus on being
interested not interesting
um and what John meant by that was you
know do those things that really move
your curiosity about other people don't
try to posture and show how amazing you
are and you will actually do a much
better job at solving problems and
having a life of real meaning
after the GSB you put those lessons into
use by founding Acumen in 2001 now at
the time impact investing wasn't a term
that many people were using or had heard
of before how did you come up with a
model for Acumen whereas you put it both
a dignity and capitalism can co-exist
so
the the banking really taught me the
power of markets as I said and also
where markets are limited in Rwanda
um which is a country which as everyone
knows went through a horrendous genocide
I really started to think think about
what does it mean to be human and
um
and what's really important to us and we
look at poverty always in terms of
income but poverty is so much more than
income poverty is a lack of choice it's
a lack of opportunity it's a lack of
agency it's a lack of feeling that you
can contribute
that's what dignity is the opposite
of that it's it's not about wealth it's
about having that choice having that
agency having that ability to contribute
and so
how do you take the best of capitalism
and also recognize where capitalism is
limited and if you could drive your
systems towards dignity not just profit
or not just feel good uh touch a lot of
people without trying helping them
transform their own lives maybe we could
do a better job I felt by then
um Kathleen that philanthropy was broken
but so were markets if we were really
focused on solving our biggest problems
of poverty and so many of those
Solutions are within our our hands so
let's try a new way
so what you were doing was new and it
was also complex when you were sharing
this idea with people early on where you
met with any skepticism and if so how
did you overcome that okay I was only
met with skepticity let's be honest
um I would literally sit on Sandhill
Road and I would pitch what I thought
was this amazing pitch to venture
capitalists because we were doing very
similar work but we were doing it in
entrepreneurs that were trying to build
companies where their customers made one
or two dollars a day where there was no
infrastructure
um where there was a lot of bureaucracy
where there's no trust where there was a
lot of corruption this was not going to
be three years and a 40 return this was
going to be 10 to 15 years and
possibly other kinds of capital but
maybe just maybe by accompanying these
entrepreneurs and giving them the right
kind of capital we could help solve
their problems and they would be well
you clearly don't understand business
um and what's painful about that and as
you all go off to disrupt the status quo
which I hope you all do
um is that there's a part of you that
think they might be right
and so how do you hold on to what you
know inside yourself has to be better
than what you're seeing because what
you're seeing isn't working for the
people that you're standing for and just
take it and now of course what I say to
people all the time is when they start
telling you you're crazy it means you're
on to something
and that is so true and that felt so
true for me uh that's not to say it's
not without real pain
I've loved watching your interviews
reading your books because you are a
fantastic Storyteller you have a way of
capturing the audience sharing your
emotions in a way that makes it seem
like the reader is there something we
learned in our classes here is the power
of Storytelling and how that can make a
major difference in both our personal
and our professional lives so what role
has storytelling played and acumen's
growth and its success
thank you Kathleen for that question
um
um I I a lot and in that same way
um I think the stories we need to tell
our stories that are full of more nuance
than
um the stories we too often hear the
stories we too often hear are might be
sexier they might prey on our desire for
candy you know not just the the spinach
that is also part of it and how do you
hold both
um I think one of the the famous times
in acumen's history was when I was uh
trying to bring we were trying to bring
Acumen to West Africa and I sat at a
table with about 18 Nigerians and
Ghanaian men
um and they were uh I was talking about
Acumen of what we were doing and that
there were all these incredible young
African entrepreneurs that were trying
to solve their continents problems and
how I'd been working there for 20 years
already or 35 years by that point and
this one man said that's really exciting
Jacqueline but aren't you a little old
to be so idealistic about Africa
and um
you know 18 men and you and you're the
only non-african sitting at the table
and I just took a breath and I was like
well I could tell you a different story
I could tell you my stories instead of
Entrepreneurship and possibility and
what people have done in that incredible
Innovation here on this continent I
could talk about the corruption and the
sabotage of the extortion I could talk
about a genocide and what I have gone
through I could talk about being held at
gunpoint and knife point
just doesn't feel that inspiring I said
you know it so happens
that um a few months ago my little
sister had brain surgery
and it left her paralyzed and the
neurosurgeons have told us that she's
never going to walk again
so when I'm in the room with my sister
do you think that's the conversation we
have
you know this really is unfortunate and
you're never going to walk again so
let's deal with it I was like no well
I'm inside the room with my sister we
talk about how I'm going to dance with
her at her wedding
when I'm outside the room
you can bet that we are talking to every
neurosurgeon we are looking at every
possible way that we might be of some
assistance in her recovery and she is
the one that's doing the work sometimes
a step forward sometimes two steps back
but she needs our belief and her hard
work
and um
and I said you know
um that's the story that we need to hold
on to in wounded communities in places
where people don't have hope
we have to be clear-eyed about the the
challenges that we face not afraid of
them but if that's all we look at
it's too easy to fall prey to despair
how do you hold that in balance with the
possibility set what we can actually
build together that's where change
happens we need more honest storytelling
we made more inspiring storytelling and
um and by the way two years later I did
dance with my sister at her wedding
and I've seen unbelievable change happen
in places that
the world sees as uh
not investable
and part of Storytelling is also doing
the work of investing so that people can
tell their own stories because
of the changes they've made
I love that now the work you were doing
also required a lot of trust both on
behalf of your partners but the people
that you were working with how did you
go about building that trust what are
some great practices that you learned
and maybe some mistakes that you made
that we shouldn't make hmm
um
I think early on where I
I I sometimes assumed that people
understood my good intent
and as you can probably already figure
out I tend to be very enthusiastic even
though I'm too old to be so enthusiastic
some people tell me
um and so I'll come in with all this
enthusiasm and people sort of want to
pull back
um and when I was younger not only did I
feel the enthusiasm but then I would be
like I will fix this system and then
you'll understand your problems and then
we can all fix them together and then
they would literally burn true story
burn all the work that I had done
um because we didn't have the online
capability nothing was in the cloud
um
the where where we've done a good job is
um probably the stuff our mother's
taught us when we were little
show up tell the truth
um accompanied people which means don't
solve their problems for them
own their problems with them and help
them build the capabilities so they
ultimately can solve their own problems
our best companies are the companies
that trust us enough to tell us when
there are problems before the problems
happen
um you have to remember sometimes too
when you're working in change and you're
building businesses
um for people who've been overlooked is
that many of them are used to telling
people across lines of power the stories
they think they want to hear
and so your job becomes
creating enough openness and
demonstrating how much that you're
listening not just with your ears but
your whole self
that gives them the permission to tell
tell you the stories that they need to
tell so that you can actually help solve
their problems
now part of acumen's Manifesto is
maintaining a hard-edged hope and
balancing humility with audacity I love
those two phrases how do you think about
those in your minds and how do we go
about finding that hope and maintaining
that balance
thanks I really do think holding values
intention is one of the most underrated
skill sets for the 21st century and it's
one that every single one of you needs
to have because our world is so complex
a single set of values no longer is
going to allow us to solve our problems
um
I I think of capitalism itself as
something I love and I hate
um the only way that you build companies
that have both purpose and profit is to
make some
extremely difficult decisions all along
the way
um but it's not just profit and purpose
it's when are you generous when are you
accountable when you listen when do you
make decisions
when do you prioritize the individual
when do you prioritize the community and
so humility audacity in a way undergirds
all of that
um
you all probably know this story but uh
to Stanford Business School students
well particularly Sam Goldman and um
Matt tozen who were taking Dean Patel's
uh
radical affordability class came up with
this solar Lantern and a dream to
eradicate kerosene back in 2006. when
they walked into our office
when solar was about four dollars a
watch with this audacious stream to
eradicate kerosene which was used by 1.5
billion people on the planet and a 30
solar lantern that really had not been
tested at all we were still at the
Prototype stage I think that was sort of
the definition of audacity and um
humility or Insanity at that point and
um
but they had such Grit
they were so ready to listen to people
Sam had spent five years living in Benin
West Africa
um and early on it was clear they had
this this tent they would hold this
tension they never lost sight of that
North Star
of eradicating kerosene and bringing
people clean affordable electricity
um
but for seven years they had to sort of
wander in the desert like so many of the
entrepreneurs in whom we invest patient
Capital because
they didn't had a price there were no
financing systems people truly didn't
trust
setting aside carriers to their kerosene
which they could pay for every single
day and if the kerosene they ran out of
money they just would live in the dark
one night now you had a real product
that if you didn't pay somebody might
take it away
hard to sell all that
um I really think that they're what I
would call their moral imagination that
humility in that audition audacity that
that stayed in tension the whole time
has helped them build a company that's
now brought light and electricity to 150
million people
um 150 million people that is moving the
needle on one of the world's toughest
problems and I just was talking to Ned
yesterday actually and they're just
getting started you know watch that
space so it's and that's humility too
because these aren't companies that
solve problems in three years
these are companies that help solve
problems in 30 years
and the early adopters have to by
definition the Pioneers build vertically
integrated companies so they're trying
to solve all the broken parts of a
non-existent ecosystem how do you
finance it how do you manufacture it how
do you distribute it how do you Market
it and um
I think that humility audacity peace is
probably the most critical value set
that's got to be held and then expand on
the hard edged hope I love that but I
hadn't heard that before I read your
book
um so there are many communities that we
work with who actually don't like the
word hope they think it's too easy
um
and in a way it's connected to the
Techno optimism that we all went through
uh in this area
um look techno technology is going to
change everything it's like well no
technology technology will change a lot
of things but let's be honest Thomas
Edison invented the light bulb 150 years
ago
even after the last 15 years of
tremendous technological progress 800
million people still have no access to
electricity and so when I speak at
conferences on AI and we keep talking
about now ai is going to change
everything
um
and it's the new electricity it's that
new birth
I keep reminding them that we still
haven't gotten everyone electricity and
so if we don't yes recognize we have
these tools and we can be hopeful about
what happens but we have to
we have to push the inevitable
we have to do the work of understanding
that this stuff is hard
there are a lot of setbacks so you have
to hold to both you have to keep that
sense of
understanding that Dawn will come
it will come and do the work to ensure
that it's bright Dawn
something I know you're very excited
about is the hardest to reach initiative
you've talked a little bit about that
but can you tell us more and what makes
you so excited
yeah um so we made this investment in
Delight
um in 2007 after speaking to the guys in
2006 and um
the
it got so exciting to us as we started
to see people take on
affordable solar light and electricity
that we ended up investing in 40
companies across this emerging ecosystem
and one of the things I didn't
understand when I started
is that to invest in enough companies
like this for long enough particularly
in a certain geography
an ecosystem really does emerge and it's
embarrassing to say this but when we
first started talking about this
emerging ecosystem I didn't really
understand what I was saying
um and then I could sort of see it but
uh it wasn't physically available
uh I was just in Kenya three days ago
and
what it looks like today is not only
light and electricity and televisions
but solar pumps and I walked into one
Delight store and
um they were selling one of our
company's cook stoves
um they brought about 20 million people
cook stoves now because solar has
created the distribution Network now for
transformative Life Products and then on
the television was another one of our
company's Achilles networks which is now
created the only educational television
station in Kenya that serves about 9
million young people
and when I was talking to that CEO he's
like well there's no way we would have
been able to reach this many young
people who are outside aren't really
getting the kind of education they need
in the traditional system without solar
televisions so I'm sitting in this tiny
little place
and I'm seeing the adjacent possible
you start with the solar and other ideas
now become possible and now you have a
distribution network but there's a
Confluence that makes me really just so
thrilled about the world that's Kenya
Kenya has gone from about
15 electrification one in 2006 to almost
90 percent and most of that is green so
it's possible
but with 800 million people left without
electricity what's the next stage where
do we go now and so we started to look
at the world and do the math and our
belief is about 550 million people
with no electricity today we'll have
them from the markets that have been
built by entrepreneurs
um many some of whom came out of this
place
and uh
and about 215 million people will will
still be overlooked they will not get
access to electricity unless we are more
radical in the way that we think about
kind of capital and the kind of systems
that allow people to get access
um most of the people without
electricity live in 22 sub-Saharan
African or African countries
um like South Sudan with the two percent
electrification rate
a Liberia about 11 percent Malawi
um I think they're at 14 percent
you can't build and develop with a 2 or
10 or 15 electrification rate
and so the hardest to reach work that
we're doing now is to go into them we're
starting with 16 Nations
um
and bring the right kind of capital in
big philanthropic parts that will allow
us to experiment
um
concessionary debt for inventory
financing and other ways of enabling
these companies to operate and hopefully
succeed
but it's all driven by the problem that
we're trying to solve and the knowledge
that we've gained over 22 years in terms
of where does Private for-profit Capital
work where is concessionary Capital
needed and where is philanthropy needed
unapologetically
so that we can then bring blueprints in
partnership with government to actually
solve the problem and um
so we're all putting our seat belts on
as we uh move forward but it's the most
ambitious thing that we've ever
undertaken and I hope it also helps this
conversation that I find
way too toxic especially in the United
States where we're so ideological about
markets versus government private sector
we it's all needed right now and um and
we're seeing that through Acumen America
as well and some of the companies that
are coming up there
a lot has happened in 22 years since you
founded Acumen in 2001 impact investing
has become a bigger thing what are some
of the trends that you've been seeing in
the space
some of the trends that excite me are
just how much money
um is going into the sector
um depends on who you talk to but
trillions and trillions
um
I really credit your generation as well
that you're a generation that
is demanding purpose is demanding impact
that recognizes that climate change is
existential
and that we need to find ways to measure
um not just the positive that our
companies create in the world but the
costs to people and to the planet
and so that really excites me what
doesn't excite me
is that we're in that phase of a whole
new sector growing where we have one
easy rubric that doesn't actually
provide any transparency or Clarity
around where you might sit within the
spectrum of people who call themselves
impact investors and so some funds feel
that any investment in Africa
is impact
kind of questionable if you look at it
very closely uh and um and so that's I
think it's very risky then because
people can easily become cynical
and feel that
uh
there's not enough truth to it and so I
think that there's an opportunity now
within the sector to be clear about what
kind of impact that you you are actually
saying that you will create and then an
accountability that you're measuring
that impact
um and offering that to both
shareholders and philanthropists because
it's becoming a spectrum of both
we talked about inequality we talked
about poverty we talked about dignity a
majority of us are going into the
private sector after we graduate what
role do private sector leaders play and
some of these huge issues that Acumen is
dealing with
look we're we're a non-profit that
um
only invest in for-profit private sector
Enterprises so uh and we have about a
quarter a quarter billion now under
management in for-profit Impact funds so
I am a clear believer in the power of
private sector leaders to help us solve
our toughest problems whether it's in
poverty or in any of the areas in which
you all are thinking about our food
systems our
um
climate in general I could go on
education
um
where I would say I have changed to is
that at the beginning I thought private
sector leaders could solve the problems
alone
because the governments and so many of
the places that we had worked were so
dysfunctional
now I have a different View and I think
it's it becomes incumbent on private
sector
leaders
to really think about the kinds of
Partnerships that are needed to solve
problems with an open mind
um
when when when philanthropists were
first coming to us to talk about
education
I was not excited to start looking for
social entrepreneurs that were trying to
solve problems of Education because I
was such a Believer and a product of
public education I felt that this was
government's fault
but when you're working in countries
where
40 percent of low-income people
are sending their kids to private school
even though they don't have any money
themselves
um you got to pay attention the humility
has to be connected to the audacity and
now we're investing in companies like
Zaraki which is a platform company
private sector that
um is only working with public sector
schools it's essentially providing a way
for teachers to access
um
through their smartphones an app that
number one allows them to
um
to input at home all of their the exam
results for all of their students on
average there's 50 kids in a class A
teacher might have 10. a school might
have three computers so prior to Zaraki
every teacher in the school would have
to wait until
a teacher before them had input all of
their individual grades into the
computer it could take months and so now
simultaneously on a Saturday on a
Saturday you could do all the grades the
teachers get it the students get it you
have it
um and so it saves your time number two
um
Isaac the entrepreneur realized that uh
that Khan Academy is such a powerful
technology
but it didn't really work for Kenya
because people didn't understand
American accents uh Kenyan is Kenya's
really focused on a testing system Etc
and so
with Khan Academy's blessing they built
for context and now they have 127 000
teachers that use it and so they can
find the best teachers in the country
and give them access to it
um
that there's more but the point is it's
a private sector company that only works
with the public sector to make the
public sector better what it should be
that is so thrilling to me and that is
actually where I think your generation
is going to be able to push boundaries
whereas My Generation had much more of a
bifurcated approach pretty much to
everything but certainly to governments
role civil societies role and business
I see I see a convergence and the best
leaders the the those leaders that have
Clarity around where does the private
sector operate best
public sector and Civil Society I think
are going to be the most successful at
solving our biggest problems
a final question before we move into
audience q a I read that you ended your
GSB Journey with a head full of dreams
for many of us in just 32 days our GSB
Journeys will be ending too
so what advice do you have for those of
us in the audience who want to turn the
dreams in our heads into reality
well first of all I just so appreciate
the those of you who came uh a month
before you are graduating uh on a
incredibly beautiful day
um because you deserve to be really
thinking about
whatever time you have before you go to
the do the next thing
um and congratulations to each of you
you're at the most extraordinary
institution and some of my very best
friends came out of this experience and
I hope you hold them forever and it's
part of my advice
if I have advice but um I think if
there's been one takeaway in my life it
is
um just start just start and let the
work teach you that so many people wait
till
they had the right kind of skills and
the enough money in the house and all
these other
um
things that are a proxy for provisional
living I'll do this when
and I now have people my age who have a
lot of regrets that they didn't do it
ever
and we all had these conversations right
where you are about what that future
would be so
um if there is a dream or even if
there's a problem that you're interested
in solving take a step toward it
and then the second piece is
and and when you fall and fail and you
will we didn't talk a lot about how hard
this is I didn't understand how hard it
is
um there are a lot of nights where
you're lonely a lot of Tears
um times where you feel like
no matter how hard you tried you're
failing
that goes with the territory of trying
to change a status quo because the
status quo exists for a reason
and therefore you need to be accompanied
you yourself
need incredible friends you need people
around you who will
double your Joys and your celebrations
and who will divide your Grieves griefs
and um carry through
and they'll also hold you to account
they won't let you start to believe when
you really do succeed
um what the world is telling you you are
because I have now
invested in 150 different entrepreneurs
and we have about 1350 fellows and I
have seen great success destroy
companies and frankly individuals and I
have seen
a great failure
make
co-founders run away
the ones who make the change are the
ones who have the grit and the
determination and a North star that they
never let go of aspiring to to reach
and um
and so back to the telling the stories
that matter it is not the easiest path
but what I can tell you is that it comes
with a deep abiding
Joy sense of meaning understanding of
what it means to be human and at the end
of the day
feeling Fully Alive and fully used up
which is certainly what I want to do
before I die
thank you for that words to live by
we're now going to move to audience Q
and A if you have a question please
raise your hand wait for the microphones
to be passed for it to you and then
stand up state your name and state your
question
Hi Jacqueline thanks so much for being
here I'm Kayla with my second year
student here and first just
thank you I read Manifesto for a moral
Revolution and I feel a lot of kinship
with your work I was a social
entrepreneur in Zambia before school
building a microgrid company and and
like what you say about you know the
multiplying effects of people having
electricity and then what else they can
have
it those were the things I was most
excited about in my in my world
um my question is ESG investing has
gained a lot of support and its share of
controversy recently what are your
thoughts on the state of ESG investing
and how can it best be used to hold
companies accountable
thanks and and Caleb thanks for the work
you do I was actually just in Zambia 48
hours ago which is why I'm a little
fuzzy ended today and it is awesome to
see what's happening there with
electricity and also the Zambian
government
really bringing the private sector in
um in new ways probably than from when
you were there it's very new
um
so ESG you can imagine I'm asked a lot
whether what we are doing is actually a
version of Woke capitalism
um
ESG is a good start and it's not enough
um the the
we with all of our for-profit funds we
are required by law to well we're
acquired in the in the
in the jurisdictions in which we're
operating to report on ESG and and I've
actually seen firsthand how it's given
us more
um insight into how our different
companies are operating and how
seriously they are taking
carbon emissions who is on their boards
uh the kinds of employees that they are
um are working with I find it really
exciting and I have to tell you at the
beginning I was not that thrilled that
we had yet another administrative uh
cost and Duty that we would have to
integrate into the investing that we
were doing
um where it's not enough is like any
system like this it's so General that
it's easy not to take it seriously
whatsoever I actually think that
we need to do much more as a world if
we're very if particularly around
climate if we're serious
to measure
um
both carbon emissions as well as what's
happening to the people that we are
working with
um
our food companies
for the most part are are working with
people who uh
can't afford to they're they're growing
our food and they can't afford to feed
their families
the our oil companies continue to
operate without the kind of
accountability that we need to see in
the world
um and there's also real benefits I
think I think that we're going to see I
hope
that your generation is going to help us
here too when you look at a country like
Kenya with almost 90 green energy that
should be an amazing advantage
in the 21st century for a nation to be
able to invite heavy industry in with
low-cost labor and with clean energy
but it will only truly be that if we
start to account for it and we hold our
companies to Greater account
I see it starting to happen at the edges
which to me means there's real
opportunity if we build that momentum to
bring it into the center so I think ESG
is a start
um that's not good enough
yeah I was wondering um how do you think
about your Storyteller Journey you talk
a lot about story and I remember in
other argument documents about how
important storytelling is I would love
to ask you about what how do you develop
your own story and what was the journey
for you as a Storyteller if you compare
yourself to you know 20 some years ago
when you started the first pitch has it
changed a lot or has it remained the
same or what's your experience
huh
um
I grew up with a mother who is not just
a Storyteller but she's a great myth
maker
um
so it took me a while to actually get
rid of the myths tell the truth so uh I
always saw the power of Storytelling
um and
when I
I would say especially when I started
acumen
what killed me is that I would meet
incredible social entrepreneurs some of
the best
who
couldn't really tell their stories
themselves
and there was this one man who has
changed he's fundamentally changed the
world I don't want to say his name only
because he's so special to me but
he inspires me every day like John
Gardner does and um and I brought him
to my tiny apartment and I brought some
potential investors and he was so humble
and he spoke so softly
and it took him like 27 minutes to
actually tell the group what he did by
which point everybody was on there I
think they were blackberries at the time
um and I was just mortified
mortified that these guys who
could have really made change
um
we're bored
and that this man who had spent his
whole life
fundamentally changing a Health Care
System wasn't being effective in telling
his story that was a real moment for me
um that
it's not enough
just to have a great Enterprise
particularly in the social sphere where
you're already fighting so many elements
that aren't really interested in you
succeeding or they think that what
you're doing is really worthy inspiring
but not like
Hammer at home change get out of my way
we have to hold those that soft in the
heart too a great moment was we brought
15 of the Acumen fellows or 17 of the
Acumen fellows to the Ted conference
this year
and we had a lunch and I was thinking
either we have four tell their stories
or
everyone tell their story but that means
we have essentially 18 minutes for 18
talks
um and thought okay this will actually
push the limit can they tell their
stories which are Super complex
from all around the world in ways that
will land with people it took a lot of
work from each of these individual
fellows
um
but they pulled it off and to sit there
and hear you know I take flowers from
the Ganges and I turn them into insects
incense sticks and I'm doing vegan
leather and I just signed a contract
with Tommy Hilfiger boom next and you
know I started off in in Pakistan doing
education
um using a tech platform but it didn't
really work so now I'm working with uh
teachers in their schools and I have 700
schools and 12 million people are
watching my thing boom and you just
listen to unless this rainbow of
possibility and competency and I just
sat there like this is what storytelling
looks like
um and it was impossible to sit in that
room including for me without being
transformed by these stories and none of
them were more than a minute long except
for one guy who took 10 extra seconds
and then we all done after but that is
you know that is what great storytelling
is can you pull it to the essence
brilliant
thank you for your questions it is View
from the top tradition you may be aware
to end with a lightning round so I'll
ask a few short questions and you'll
answer with the first thing that pops
into your head that's very dangerous
ready go favorite class at the GSB well
John Gardner at leadership
uh favorite hobby outside of work
running
your personal mantra
um
I think just start and let the work
teach you
and something the world needs more of
if there's a single thing that we the
world needs more than anything in every
system that we are witnessing
it's gonna make me cry almost it's a
it's consciousness
it's it's
compassion for one another
we are in this moment of
just extraordinary technological
acceleration
our challenge is to ensure that our
moral reasoning
our moral imagination our moral courage
keeps Pace without acceleration
I really believe
after all the hard and sometimes ugly
things that I have experienced in the
worlds that maybe met more than ever
before that our love for each other
I love for the planet must Prevail over
our thirst for power and our thirst for
profit
and I also believe that it's in it's
within our reach that
for 40 years I've been going around the
world and meeting and living in and
loving
communities that have been overlooked
underestimated
sometimes
used as inputs rather than seen as fully
human wanting to contribute
and I truly believe that that's changing
that I'm now seeing
I keep saying a generation but I'm
seeing it across generations of people
saying the only way we get out of this
is with each other and through each
other
and it gives me that hard Edge tote
Kathleen
that you asked about
that
if we saw ourselves as
real agents and we focused on giving
more more to the world than we take from
the world
and if you're in this room you've got
more
than almost anybody in history
more access
more skills more brilliance
and an amazing Network that's only going
to grow
and so
how do you take that
because the more that you give
the more that the world gives you and
loves you back in ways that you might
never have been able to imagine
and I just
I just wish all of you this incredible
journey that I know is ahead of you
and I hope that you hold each other
close
for the whole long journey that you have
and I just feel so lucky that I got to
be last even though I feel guilty about
it too
um
and Godspeed
I love that Jack when you were the last
speaker of this year's we have made back
there many times
but we we've now had eight incredible
leaders who have taught us and shared
their insights for how to make the world
a better place and how we too can change
lives change organizations and change
the world and now as you said we just
have to start so thank you it's been an
honor thank you
foreign
[Music]